here's the quick breakdown war zone
rated 58 players 18 24 60 players 18 24
average rating time handicap
time and position handicap here we go
you know what i could pull off this was
not fixed just yet
the blue
chicken gambit can happen at any moment
there's some explanation and i'm sure to
those that are new
you
know what i'm talking about though
blue chicken actually my knight wants to
be on g5
let's go g5
get that light square bishop
get the light squared bishop and then
open up this side of the board
where are we gonna go next time
time time time time time they're chewing
time they're chewing a lot of time let's
open this up
they're going to grab that pawn
uh-oh
uh oh i don't want to move my pawn to c4
because d5 is played and the d file
opens up
let's do this
take here and then i think i want to
castle queen side no king side
no don't do that
and oh i'm no i'm on the night but i the
queen is defending if the knight plays
here
i just want my rook on b1 let me do this
my dark star bishop is stupid let's play
here
making one threat mate in one threat
making one threat
it's defended
but i get a rook
is there something better i'm just gonna
do this
just to burn time
time oh no i just got my queen
wait that's me no it's not
that's not me
anything though they're down on time
back to tournament
two two two the big bad wolf
is up there billy oh no no no no um no
no no f pawn that's what i was trying to
get out there
okay so that means as soon as i castle
i'll pressure on f7
can i get that quickly
i have a center
can i build it build that center build
the center
c4 this shut down that bishop
and then do what
no no no
don't you dare try to expand on the
queen side
no
okay i got to take that bishop of plays
here
i also got to take that and i want to
keep my bishop around here pawn push is
probably going to happen soon
i'll take the knight maybe
or maybe not root to d8 i think
oh that can't be right can it
this square is really weak
really weak he's gotta go
oh i shouldn't have done that
the queen's gonna come out here and kill
me
can i get this pawn and then back it up
i have my queen here to defend i want to
bump my king up actually let's do this i
want to take that pawn
i was color bishop i need to hang onto
this guy i can't let him fall
let's try this
is this working
no i'm gonna end up in a pin the queen
just has to move she didn't move
she has to move but she didn't move be
scared be very scared be scared
chakarooski's
chekaruski's
okay let's lock that up pawn push my
[ __ ] has to run away scared no what no
time though i almost took that
i almost took that okay let's do this
trades they don't have any time
no time
get active rook
get active rook
no time
pre-moves
right here sneaky stuff
or this oh maybe me that would i should
have made do i have mate i have close to
mate no i don't
back to tournament
oh six six six six six four
let's roll here oh no f pawn again who
are these 2100s
can i get that f-file get that get out
of there knight
get that f-file real quick
oh
don't bother my bishop
over here
over here don't trap don't trap my
bishop
don't trap my bishop
oh it would be pinned if i did that
don't do that
i gotta break this up no don't drop that
i still can't take that pun
ah
let's do this can i get that pawn or
something
give a check that's not working
let's back up oh what a disaster
what disaster knight right here you know
you want to be there tonight oh
bad news
bad news they're out of a pin and i'm in
trouble
where are the time burners
no i'm i'm glad i'm out slipped on that
one
i was ready to lose i was ready to lose
a piece if that wasn't a mouse slip
oh
hang on watch out for sneaky stuff
everywhere
watch out for that sneaky stuff how much
time is left
no time no time no time pigs there's a
pig right there
is he trapped no he's not trapped he's
close to trapped
right here pawn up on up
oh deadly pin i don't like being in that
pin
oh ooh
ooh oh i got a piece back i got a piece
back i got a piece back again i got
another one come on my knight wants to
be on g6 give a check it's coming to g6
g6 i'm liking the g6 i'm liking the g6
i'm gonna take it it's immediate one
threat come on run rook
run rook give a check grab a pawn give
another check more checks grab puns
pre-move pre-move keep pre-moving run
but not too fast okay step ladder you
love step ladders step ladders is this
mate it's mate
back to tournament 14 12 12. wow pieces
were falling everywhere right there dodo
total
dodo79 is on the scene here
oh
man
too intense way too intense here
let's go knight f6 castle
oh i'm in a pin i'm in a pin
let's get out of the pin
oh
let's get to f5 f4 you know what i meant
f4 it's a juicy square
very very juicy square this knight needs
to get out of there though
get out of there night
okay do this first then pawn push
does that work
forks no that's not working i just want
to break at this point
let me take the rook first chase that
bishop elsewhere take the knight next
and then i get to f4
let's take this
uh my knight's gonna get kicked away
i really didn't want to have to do that
but he's gonna reroute to d6 hopefully
hopefully real quick
he's going to be challenged okay he's a
challenged knight
he's a challenge knight knight f4
knight f4 keep him right here
forks watch out for the tricky forks
watch out for the tricky forks
tricky forks everywhere
get out of there bishop i cannot deal
with you
oh
what am i doing right here give a check
my rook needs to do something else let's
give a check
um
oh the queen could block i almost missed
that i was going to pre-move this
oh is it mate it's might be on the king
is running for the hills
he's running for the hills
oh if i no no no no no no right here
easy does it now
could have played here as well
watch out for the checks watch out for
the tricky checks give a check here they
don't have any time they can't win this
over here i just dropped my queen i just
dropped my queen don't take it yes they
didn't take it right here let's try this
again bishop takes queen was there
oh
was that scary or what
that was scary for me
that was definitely scary
pawn push pawn push
pawn push
pawn push back to tournament
get back here 36 lancaster's up there
again
king on pre
move why didn't i move there 21 there's
a lot of time left you have to keep
winning
you have to keep winning stay focused
now
stay focused 21
21 minutes left you can do this you can
do it fight back
you know who's your best friend
that's my little pep talk you know who's
your best friend
who knows what i'm talking about
you know what i'm talking about best
friend my best friend is the clock this
pond is going down but i want a castle
and then pile up pile up on the h foul
that was a bait he took the bait forks
forks diagonals
open the diagonal you know you just want
to capture capture whoa
where'd that come from
whoa the kitchen sink variation
wow the diagonal has been opened up
ah just chop here pieces are being
chopped left and right chops chops chops
chops
watch out for the tricky mates
grab the knight grab the knight give a
mate
i'm setting it up grab a knight give a
mate that's the plan
grab a knight no yes and then mate here
making one threat making one got it back
to tournament 30 somebody has 50 they
have seven not a seven
whoa
dark side one
dark side
let's go less than 20 minutes
remaining oh
man that queen is having fun
wow she's a dancing queen
the dancing queen is on the scene here
oh
okay okay i got some material back
get out of there knight i cannot deal
with you
can i get another piece okay okay no no
no what am i trying to do with that pun
okay easy does it what's the clock
situation
um let's try this
why'd i do that
oh oh oh i know why
if you take i have this
and okay now i'm hitting two things two
things
oh the rook is cooked cooked rook
variation grab the rook trade pieces
oh sneaky
they missed that one watch out for back
rank mates
pinned knight
pin night coming up pin night coming up
mate in one threat pig
pig on the second and first
they resigned back to tournament 66
42 30. who is this guy lancaster he was
in uh those two earlier tournaments and
he's back again
rattling off eight out of eight if i get
paired up i'm gonna start off with what
a few pieces somebody knock him off
somebody knock off lancaster
get rid of lancaster do whatever you
need to do
take them out
take them out
high eagle this is high eagle right here
if you put your pawn in the center i
push a pawn in the center it's as easy
as that keep it real simple
keep it closed in other words knight g3
f5 incoming
landing spot
let's support it a bit
is it still going to be played you're
going to take my knight first
i got a pawn
i'm fighting back a little bit
just a hair
bishop here i can't do that
oh okay
a little scary here or a lot scary i
gotta castle queen side king side can't
castle through check you know that you
know better
you know better oh there goes the queen
there goes the queen
and now let's try and okay my opponent
does have three minor pieces for the
queen
are they just going to resign they
resigned back to tournament 56 i needed
that
oh
who what does he have
what does he have i could throw the blue
chicken gambit once again but i'm not
going to go that route i'm not going to
go that route i had my fun with it i'm
not going to clean side castle and win
because of the glitch
if you're new to that what happens is if
i go to queenside castle
um
i just move my king and then uh their
clock
it doesn't read on their uh on their
side that i have moved
and it's just their clock that's
actually burning they don't they don't
know what hit them
they don't know what hit them
it's a very very
deadly deadly combination you never want
to fall for
where you just don't know what hit you
and that's what the blue chicken gambit
does so queen here i could give a check
and similar to that last game i'll get
the queen where else did she go here
that's our only safe square oh similar
to last game
the queen is cooked
wait a second there might be something
with night here but no not right away
i think i just want to take that knight
before it's uh
too late
or the bishop
okay my queen would like to get active
and right here is a good square hang on
sneaky stuff right here tricky nights
everywhere
flush this knight away
oh bishop bishop move first
bishop's going to hit my rook or not
uh let's come here my king is maybe
going to have to bump up i think it
could be okay here whoa
that's pretty crazy
and take here i want to control this
square that's the main idea that's why
i'm not going with my queen to recapture
get that knight out of here right here
check oh i had this move i'm hitting the
knight though
i think i'm getting material back oh
they're down on time back to tournament
104.
whoa
whoa whoa whoa 104.72
15 minutes we're about halfway there
maybe if i get paired up with
that guy i could uh get a win but he's
uh difficult enough to beat
with
just the
you know the material balance and i
think i'll be down upon her too
um
let's support that i guess d5 could come
i want to be able to recapture
um with my d-pawn
let's come here that's going to be hit
anyhow
let's weasel around to c2 and then
hit this knight look for mate on h7
uh oh
are they scared
let's try this take my knight i do this
oh no no no
what am i doing what am i doing just
play here i don't even know what that's
doing what does that move even do
i don't even know what that move is even
doing
i need to get rid of this knight why'd i
uh he's so tough he's a tough guy
he is definitely a tough guy right there
i have this covered twice what's the
clock count i need to win every game
okay get out of a pin guard this pawn
pawn push pawn push
oh
let's try this
i want to get at this knight
double up double up double up double up
f5 incoming f5 you know you want to be
on f5 right now my light square bishop
is a giant idiot
big idiot right here do something
different kill that knight
get rid of that bishop my night with
look at the clock situation my queen is
dead no she's not
come on i gotta go quicker
right here just take my bishop already
would you
just get rid of them
g4
no no no
push is my not gonna get hit
are they gonna move they're not gonna
move i could no i could grab here that's
what they're afraid of
okay let's guard here hang on hang on
hang on
hang on hang on
i'm catching up on time i'm catching up
on time
my queen is running out of squares i
gotta kick that knight away
oh oh oh
let's try this recapture with my knight
and then
oh
man i gotta kick that night away
you definitely oh i'm on the queen
i'm on the queen she doesn't have very
many choices they're down on time i got
the night i got the knight making one
threat me one hang on hang on to my
knight watch out for mates on g2
whatever you do do not fall for that
mate
don't you dare clock situation i got the
rook
free
main maintenance ii if they take this
to me they haven't moved they can
tournament 90. whoa
he has 11 games 124 11 out 11 is
fantastic
12 minutes remaining
oh
let's go here
let's go
because
that guy needs to hit a speed bump where
are the speed bumps
i get this in
they're gonna be sneaky
that's not made is it whoa this is
really close to me don't play here queen
or bishop whatever you do do not play
there
don't play there again
just move a knight or a light square
bishop
ah
i need to keep my queen on the board
let's castle d5
d5 on the bishop open this up here
my knight out grab here
checks here
okay this is uh breaking open i think
i'm in a better position now
oh i'm definitely in a better position
okay
night watch out for tricks
where is that mate right here open up
the
this file right here checks
oh the queen has to block or the knight
the queen or the knight this is made in
one
queen here
okay okay check like this where's the
mate upon us to block
here
guard the rook maintaining one or two
that's mate that's mate that's made back
to tournament 110 oh i inched up he
dropped back he must have lost the game
12 to 11 he's got 122.
i see hope i see hope
oh
i see hope here 110 i got 110 i'm in
second
i don't know who's on my heels i'm just
looking forward here
i just keep looking forward
i'm not looking behind here i'm not
looking at my heels
oh no you don't because the knight would
play to h4
do not allow that to happen
no way okay i guess this is going to be
coming off i could uh
once again blue chicken it whoa i get
that piece
why am i not moving
why did i not move on that one
i had a brain cramp right there that was
a brain cramp when i wasn't saying
anything for two seconds
my mouse was just fishing around for
pieces
i didn't know what to do let's give a
check and grab this night
okay and now they're in check again
and i think i kicked this night away
chop here get my queen here my dark
square bishop
oh they're dropping stuff
okay
i would like to get my queen where
where's the dream square right here
dream square i'm looking for the dream
squares
where are they queen on e6 and my bishop
on h6 to deliver mate
oh
there goes that um
there you go those chips and i never
said what chips i was eating either
whoever gets sour cream and onion you
were right you got that one
well done
uh queen of d5
night position
knight position okay well this isn't
going to end is it just can't end easy
can't end quickly can it okay push do
this
okay
and then probably no no no
not so fast i should probably just do
this no matter what
let's move move move move anything
anything anything at all
anything at all anything at all pre
moves
pawn push back to tournament 130 142
it's doable eight minutes and change
eight minutes and change right here
right here
if we get paired up that's going to be a
big one king's attacker
oh no these are so difficult to win
oh
i hate not having my bishop puns i
really miss my bishop hans right now
oh man these are so tough
so tough
give me that light square bishop oh ooh
i got the light squared bishop can i put
my light square bishop to good use we're
going to see about that
uh oh are they scared they might be
scared
they might be scared
pins can i get the pins where the pins
that's not a good one
definitely not a good one they could
just
take oh
let's try this let's get this i think
they could take because my bishop was
unprotected there i'm trying to get the
knight and then crash through here
let's get rid of
now let's throw this in that night isn't
going to go anywhere just yet maybe rook
let me hit the rook first and then take
here or something
time burn
time burners
okay
materials balance with the clock count
just take my rook help my king out would
you
yes okay my king wants to play where
oh man i didn't want to have to give
that up
tricky night though
fear the tricky night
give a check and grab this pawn
okay king position next
why are they moving
tricky knight where's okay king position
i could get this pawn next this is a one
king upon end game
is anything oh they're getting that pun
oh no not that pawn
it's still it's still one king upon end
game right
let's just hang on to the night he's
tricky
he's a tricky knight hang on to him
give a check
come over here are they going to do a
pawn push sneaky pawn push
i'm just going to take that
they don't have any time they're
dropping stuff
everything's falling tricky night tricky
night tricky night tricky night checks
more checks
they're not um their clock isn't running
the clock isn't running tricky night
come on okay there we go back to
tournament i have a lead i have only
12 out of 12. no i don't have a lead
he's back up he's got a 10 point lead
oh for a split second i had
oh i was seeing the first place confetti
right there for a split second
i split second and then it vanished
he said no i will maintain
the first place status right there
that one took a while to come out didn't
it okay connect the knights e4 oh
here we go
queen to e2 push this knight around
let's play c4 first so i can't pivot on
d5 when i play here okay let's do this
and then follow up with this
f6 or d6
this seems good dark squares
where are the dark squares here's the
plan smashed through here and i think
it's winning
it's winning
i think this is a winning shot
this is making one two just move move
move move move mate yes that was a quick
win 170. that's what i needed five
minutes and change 170 160 123
let's go stay focused here stay focused
these are not easy games don't you dare
try to trade okay
let's go be sneaky don't drop pieces
though
be sneaky but don't drop pieces
okay get that queen up
that knight is such a pain whenever i do
this then okay let's do it now you can
always make make use of that h5 square
here we go night on the rim not so grim
uh oh tricky checks get the dark square
bishop
dark square bishop coming up
we're not let's open up this i want to
get at this point
queen bishop
do some damage here the knight goes here
i play f5 like a queen side castle
i don't want to trade queens this back
up queen side castle coming up and then
f5 the knight is uh in trouble i think
on the edge right here pawn push i play
f5
oh this is trouble
i'm pretty sure this is big big trouble
really big trouble here
um
i'm on the rook i'm on this pond as well
i'm on this pond
i want to get in uh
knight takes pawn here or pawn push
okay let's check i have this guarded
that's got to be taken i think whoa
okay let's take here throw this knight
in the pin all pawn push is gonna be
played i should have okay it's not oh i
should have just played here right away
they're in a pin
okay the night is ready to fall and i'm
on the bishop at the end of it
with check
and let's just take here and actually
i'm winning a lot of stuff now
oh i'm on the queen
i'm on that queen
clock situation
where's the checks where's the mates
let's grab this knight
let's take here
anything they are flying they're going
really fast
clock situation is what they're down on
time no they're back there's a checkmate
oh they dropped back 158
they dropped back somebody's beating
them up i have a big lead now unless
they're ready to win right now and they
can go from 158 to 178
and then they're just 12 away from
my score i'm at 190.
let's go
are you you could see that in the stream
i forgot
upper right
okay let's go
chase that knight away open up the g
file
i'm prepping it
just take the knight so i can get the g
file
okay i have the g file
mate threats mate threats mate threats
this is check and then mate by force
by four so that's a quick win two ten
whoa i was not expecting that one that
was actually maintain two
unavoidable right there 245.
mr
who i didn't mean to do that first move
stay focused stay focused
whatever you do
stay focused there okay i got a giant
pawn wall this guy is flying he's having
none of my uh nonsense here i'm gonna
try and catch him in a pre-move maybe
can i catch him in a pre-move
come on oh there's a pre-move oh
farkarooski forks everywhere
kill a rook position a knight grab a
pawn in the center
grab this guy right now
uh oh dark squares kill this
kill this no no no no no no
forks forks forks forks
watch out for tricks forks f4 f4
forks forks everywhere
deadly forks everywhere more checks
queen position i have this covered
bishop check this is winning the queen
the night is pinned
clean check
going crazy
what do we have what do we have what do
we have
the rook could be taken just gobble
stuff up give a check come over here
watch out for mates
or stalemates i mean
watch out for those stalemates
just oh queen here i think no matter
what it's mate real soon
really soon that's mate that's me back
to tournament 2 30.
i think i have it
that's a big lead somebody knocked that
guy off he must have had one or two
losses
230 178 141
oh man this is the last game one minute
two seconds
one minute
left 2 30.
i have
um
are they going to move they're not going
to move
49 48 47 46
you can't see the clock i quit on my uh
it's on the bottom right underneath that
little
thing that i have there
this is a i don't know something must he
must have dropped back somebody stopped
him in his tracks there
for me to have this lead now so
um less than 30
there's not going to be a quick win here
i'm down to rook
let's keep going i'm dropping this pawn
let's keep it close get my knight here i
could pretty much pre-move this one
can i
and
seven six
five four
three
two
one that's it completed it's saying
g file
there it is first place confetti the
long awaited
the long-awaited confetti
oh man
what a struggle
ah
man
good games oh
lancaster must have fell off a bit in
second lancaster dust cat i had 16
you're 18 games 16.
all right